Welcome to FOSSDA, the Free and Open
Source Stories Digital Archive Foundation.
It's the 6th of June, 2023, and
I am Elisabetta Mori, a historian of
computing currently based in Italy, and an
oral history interviewer with FOSSDA.
Today, I'll be talking to software engineer,
Eric Allman, author of the mail transfer
agent, Sendmail.
We are recording on TheirStory.io, and I
am in Rio, in Elba, in Elba
Island, Italy, and Eric is in Berkeley,
California.
Welcome, Eric.
Thank you.
Thank you for being here today.
Where and when were you born?
I was born in Oakland, which is
the next town over from Berkeley.
And back in 1955, which I sometimes
wonder how old I'm getting to be
now, and moved when I was about
two and a half, three maybe, to
El Cerrito, which is a town on
the other side of Berkeley.
And then at some point I moved
into Berkeley.
So I've been, I think of myself
as a Berkeley boy through.
Hello?
Yes, hi.
We had a glitch there.
Okay.
So, can you describe your parents?
Sure, my mother was a basically spent
her life in education.
She was a school teacher originally in
the Head Start program and later became
a regular classroom teacher and at some
point got her master's degree and moved
up to the principal role, which she
did for the rest of her career.
My father was, when I was born,
was an adman for the Richmond Independent,
which was a local paper, long gone
now.
And at some point he and my
mother divorced, and so I'm not as
completely clear about what he was doing
after that, but he stayed in advertising
for a while and wrote a newspaper
column called Art Who, which was an
art critic column, and at some point
kind of retired and was at that
point just sort of an art collector.
Oh, we did art brokering for a
while too.
And my mother passed away a couple
years ago, and my father, actually my
mother passed away about five years ago,
and my father passed away about two
years ago, maybe three.
I'm sorry.
What about your siblings?
I have one sister, Kat, who...
How can I put this?
My sister was, you know, if I
was the kind of mathematical one in
the family, she was the, you know,
humanities person.
And she had, I think, a difficult
time because I was considered to be
the great student and she always felt
like she was in my shadow.
And what's happened is, in fact, she
ended up going to work at Google
very early on doing open source developer
relations and I don't know I think
she was there 15 years, which is
pretty amazing and she's recently left and
I think she's still contemplating whether she
wants to retire or you know go
for another job.
What was your family life like?
My family life?
Well, as I mentioned my parents got
divorced when I was quite young.
And so I came from what they
used to call back then a broken
family, although I don't think there was
anything particularly broken about it.
My mother was an absolutely wonderful mother
who, you know, was at one point
going to school, had a full time
job and raising two kids by herself
and never seemed to break a sweat.
It was quite astounding.
When she was going to school, my
sister and I would sometimes, actually most
of the time, spend summers at my
grandparents' place.
That would be her parents.
And they lived out in the country
in Sebastopol.
So there was a, what was it,
12-acre, I think, forest to explore and
so forth.
So, you know, not a bad way
to spend your summers.
A little lonely, I guess, because they
were down at the end of a
dirt road and there just weren't anyone
my age around.
But that was fairly informative, yes.
So which schools did you attend and
what were your favorite subjects?
I'll skip kindergarten.
I went to actually a couple of
different, we called them junior high schools.
They're called middle schools now and then
I ended up at El Cerrito High
School which might as I've already intimated
my specialties seem to be like math
and science.
No particularly great surprise, but, you know,
I did other things too.
In high school, at, I think my
sister's suggestion, I got involved doing work
in the theater, which was a really
astounding thing.
I did sound, and making sound effects
was quite interesting.
At one point I had to make
the sound of a train crash.
That was fun.
How did you do it?
I went into the theater when no
one was around and laid a ladder
on the stage, piled chairs on top
of the ladder, tied a rope around
the ladder and pulled the whole thing
onto the ground.
I think I then, you know, slowed
it down or something like that a
little bit and so forth.
It was pretty cool.
So let's talk about university.
You went to University of California, Berkeley
in 1973?
Yes.
And you got a Bachelor in Electronic
Engineering and Computer Science in 1977 and
a Master of Science in Computer Science
in June 1980.
So what are your memories of those
years?
I was not a particularly happy kid
in high school.
You know, I did well in classes
and so forth, but I never really
felt connected to my peers.
I think part of that, in fact,
I'm sure part of it was, you
know, by high school I had realized
that I was gay, but I was
still very much in the closet.
And attitudes then were not as forgiving
as they are today.
And so, I kind of started over
from scratch when I went to Berkeley.
And I have only kept in touch
with a couple of people from my
high school days.
The Berkeley was great for me.
It helped that I had no social
life because that way I could do
all of my homework.
And remember, you know, physics problem set
was all day Saturday and math problem
set was all day Sunday.
So, and I was taking computer classes.
So back in high school, actually in
junior high school, there was a teacher,
I guess a math teacher at a
different school when I was in who
decided it would be cool to do
an after-school program teaching kids how to
program, Fortran to be precise.
And I got involved with that and
learned Fortran.
So I already knew some computer languages
when I got into Berkeley, which gave
me a definite leg up because, you
know, it wasn't like today where everyone
learns coding in, you know, elementary schools.
So..
so was there any particular reason why
you chose Berkeley?
You know, when I was a little
kid, my parents would take me over
to campus and I would play in
the Strawberry Creek.
You know, Berkeley campus was just sort
of part of my life and always
had been.
And I can't even remember if I
even applied to any other schools.
It just, it seemed like the obvious
thing.
There were other practical issues.
My mother was still a schoolteacher at
that point.
And, you know, frankly, we didn't make
very much money.
And so this way I could live
at home, commute into campus.
And so combination of good school, familiar
place, money, And I don't know, it
just, it's always felt right.
That's, you know, fairly obscure, I guess,
but, you know, the computer science at
Berkeley, computer science department existed, but it
wasn't the powerhouse that it is today.
So it wasn't like I was going,
oh that's the best school in the
country for it.
It probably is today, but not then.
Was there any particular episode that you
remember from those years?
Many of them.
I was a pretty obnoxious kid back
then.
You know, dealing with all this emotional
stuff going on with me, left me
kind of hostile and so forth.
I think about it now and wonder
how anyone put up with me at
all.
And in particular, I would be in
classes where somebody was teaching programming and
if they made even the slightest mistake,
I would interrupt the professor and point
out his mistake.
That did not endear me to people,
but it did give me a reputation.
And at some point there was a
brand new research project called the Ingress
Project Interactive Graphics and Retrieval System, which
was actually a database management system.
It wasn't in the name.
And it was one of the first
relational databases around.
There were two projects in the whole
world doing relational databases.
One of them was Ingress at Berkeley
and the other was System R from
IBM and San Jose.
And so Mike Stonebreaker, who was the
PI, principal investigator on Ingress, You know,
I guess actually he was supposed to
be my undergrad advisor as well.
Anyway, he suggested that I might come
up, come in as a part-time Senior
Engineering Aid was I think the title,
which, you know, I got paid, which
seemed like an immense amount of money
because I never had any money before
then.
It was, you know, probably $800 a
month or something like that, but it
was greater than zero.
And so I ended up being dropped
into a grad school setting when I
was a sophomore and that definitely changed
my life that was an amazing experience
and I can probably tell stories for
hours about that, but I won't bore
you.
Just tell one.
Sorry?
Just tell one, Ben.
Just one.
Part of the thing that was interesting
about the Ingress project is we were
doing some really cutting edge research.
It was also pretty laid back.
And so people would be, you know,
have other side projects that they were
doing, and I had a bunch of
side projects, some of which I've become
quite well known for.
And that freedom allowed me to explore
a lot of things that I, if
I was just, you know, in the
standard undergraduate program, I never would have
been exposed to.
And the other thing was the Ingress
project was working on Unix, which was,
I think, Unix, when I first started,
it was Unix version 4.
And quickly it went up to 5
version 5 and then version 6 for
a long time.
But I got to kind of, ride
the Unix wave at the same time.
And that was also a growth experience
and I started going to youth conferences
and met a lot of people.
So, you know, serendipitous.
So, during the years at Berkeley, you
worked on Ingress Project, but also in
the early 1980s, you designed DeliverMail.
Can you tell us about it?
Yes.
So the Ingress Project at some point
got a DARPA grant- Defense Advanced Research
Projects Agency, which meant we had a
link to the ARPANET.
The ARPANET is the network that existed
before the internet.
And it was a small network, you
know, a couple hundred machines on the
entire network, couldn't grow any larger than
that.
But there was enough going on that
everyone in the department wanted an account
on our machines so that they could
connect to the network.
And, um, we didn't have a particularly
big machine because, you know, we didn't
have a massive brand.
So we said, okay, we can free
up two RS-232 ports, just a simple
text only way to connect to the
machine.
And since these ports cost, you know,
500 bucks a piece or whatever, it
was just..we told other people if you
want more you can pay for it
yourself, basically.
And nobody wanted to pay for it
themselves.
So there were two ports being shared
by the entire department.
And you can imagine this got into
some uncomfortable situation.
And at that point, I was already
sort of the main system administrator for
that machine.
And so I was, of course, the
person they complained to.
And usually, of course, they couldn't do
anything about it, but they complained to
me anyway.
And at some point, I made the
observation that what most people wanted access
to was email.
Now, it turns out we already had
a- another very slow, also terminal-based network
called Birknet, which was a project done
by a guy named Eric Schmidt, who
later became CEO of Google.
So I worked with Eric.
And it would send mail, but only
inside the campus.
It wouldn't go out.
And similarly, mail from ARPANET wouldn't go
to another machine.
And so I said, you know, Birknet
is software, ARPANET is software, and I
know how to write software.
I'll bet I can find some way
to glue these things together so you
can get your email on your home
machine, not on your machine.
And that was a quick hack called
DeliverMail.
And I won't say it worked well,
but it did work and so I
basically wrote Deliver Mail to get people
to stop bothering me.
Can you describe Eric Schmidt?
Eric was driven.
You know, I think we all you
know all the students kind of knew
that Eric was going to be CEO
of a big company someday because, you
know, he got a dual major in
business and computer science.
And, you
know, I got along with Eric, but
he could be a pain in the
butt sometimes, actually.
On the other hand, I could too,
so it was only fair.
But yeah, he, I mean, I think
genuinely he was, he had in his
head that he was going to be
CEO of a major corporation.
He just focused his entire life on
that.
And he succeeded.
Okay, let's go back to your life
and career.
So what about SendMail?
Okay, so one of the superstars at
Berkeley was a guy named Bill Joy.
And, um, Bill Joy at some point
did a, uh, distribution.
So back then it was kind of,
suppose you'd call it early days of
what we call open source software.
It wasn't really because there was open
source software back in the 50s.
The IBM share conference was called share
because it was specifically about, hey, you
know, here's a tape of the stuff
I've been working on, give me a
tape of what you've been working on.
So just give us a swap meet.
Usenix got to be very much like
a swap meet as well.
And there were a bunch of people
in the area who were actively working
on Unix and developing it and whatnot,
including Bill and a bunch of others
at Berkeley and Tom Farran at the
UC San Francisco.
And so, I mean, there were some
really exciting meetings in Bill's office sometimes
where you get all of these, you
know, super high powered people hogging the
whiteboard.
I guess it was actually chalkboards back
then.
Ken Thompson came out to Berkeley on
sabbatical for a year.
So you know, I have actually I
have here in my desk drawer a
listing of the version 6 UNIX kernel
hand-annotated because Ken actually gave a free
class, evening class, where he walked through
the Kernel and taught everyone how it
worked.
And there were, I think, maybe a
dozen people in the room.
You know, now if you were to
do something like that, of course, you
have to fire the Coliseum out.
And so it was a very, very
exciting environment to be in.
And, you know, I think I may
have lost track of the question.
I was asking you about SendMail.
Ah, yes.
So Bill did Berkeley software distributions.
Can't remember now second, third Berkeley software
distribution was getting to be kind of
to the form of a whole system
and at this point it still required
an AT&T License so it wasn't really
open source in the way that it
is today.
But since everyone who was using Unix
had to have an AT&T license, it
was kind of sort of open source
within that community.
And so Berkeley, so Bob Fabry, who
was a faculty member there, started up
the Computer Systems Research Group, CSRG, and
hired Bill and a bunch of other
people whose names you probably recognize.
And they got a grant from DARPA
to create the system for the internet,
as yet non-existent internet.
So we ended up doing the TCP/IP
stack at Berkeley, incorporating ideas from other
places.
I don't want to say we did
everything.
We were, in fact, very open to
picking up other people's work and integrating
it.
And one of the things that was
needed was a mail system.
And the mail system for the internet
was completely, utterly different than the mail
system on the ARPANET.
And so at that point, I had
done deliver mail.
And Bill came to me and said,
so Eric, you know more about email
than anyone else here.
Why don't you do it?
At that point, I was working on
the Ingress project but you know never
wanted to pass up an interesting problem.
I agreed to do this and if
I had known how hard it was
going to be I would never have
agreed to it.
It was a lot of work.
But, you know, I stuck with it.
And so when, you know, on the
day, literally there was a day when
the Internet got turned on, Sendmail was
the mail program for the entire Internet.
And it snowballed from there.
During those years you also produced Syslog.
Ah, yes.
Syslog, much less exciting I suppose, but
arguably more important, was just a way
to, for various programs to write to
a log file to say what they're
doing, which when you're writing programs that
you run them and they run and
then they stop, you can print stuff
out and so forth and that's easy
but if you're running writing a program
where it runs in the background and
you never actually see its output, it
has to have some place where you
can figure out what's going on when
it's not working.
The usual thing then was you open
a file and write to that file.
And the file is somewhere.
There was no standard for where it
should be in the file system.
So it would always be a, you
know, where do I find the log
file for this program?
It's around here somewhere.
Maybe I'll be in somebody's home directory
for all I know.
And the other thing was when you
have multiple writers that, and you're writing
to a log file, they interact with
each other and you can get alphabet
soup.
So I wanted a system where you
could send a message to a demon
that would look at the message and
then take a configuration file and tell
it where that message should be logged.
And it could be multiple places.
And that syslog is still in use.
It's been rewritten since then, but it's
still fundamentally the same thing.
It's actually, it's an internet standard now.
And so maybe not the most exciting
thing I've ever done, but possibly the
most important or impactful let me say.
What about dash MI macros?
Ah, the ME macros.
ME macros, yes.
So, yeah, there was, Unix had some
programs for doing text formatting.
And there was one early on called
Rof, which was very simple.
And then another one came along called
NROF, which was the new Rof.
Rof stood for runoff.
So it was the new runoff program.
And then there was another system that
came out compatible with NROF later called
TROF, which actually went to a photo
typesetting.
But the thing about NROF and TROF
is they were almost unusable without a
macro package because it was a brilliant
design that gave you just the very
barest tools you needed to essentially implement
your own language.
And Berkeley had nRoth and I think
actually had tRoth but it did not
have a macro package.
AT&T wouldn't release that.
And so I decided I was going
to build one because I really wanted
to use NROF.
And so I ended up doing the
ME macros and learned a lot about
NROFand TROF and typesetting.
And, you know, I still have my,
you know, PICA ruler here and so
forth from when I was measuring stuff
out.
And yeah, it got used a lot
at Berkeley and did get distributed.
You can still find it on pretty
much any Unix distribution, but mostly people
use other tools today.
So, you know, it was cool though.
I think the best thing about it
was, so back then when students were
getting their PhDs, they had to get
it typed up or, you know, we're
starting to get to the point where
it's typeset.
And it goes to the something graduate
office.
And there's a woman there who like
pulls out a ruler and makes sure
all of the margins are exactly right
and so forth.
And if they're not, she says, go
away, come back when you get it
right.
She was called the Dragon Lady.
And so I added in a macro
called .th for thesis, and that just
set all the settings right so it
would get past the dragon lady.
And that made me a very popular
guy.
And you also wrote Trek, the Unix
version of Star Trek video game.
Yes.
It's not the first Trek version, although
I did make some enhancements.
There was one written in, I think
it was Fortran, that somehow I came
across.
I think I must have played it
somewhere at one point and said this
is pretty cool but it should run
on the computer that I actually have
access to and so I started working
on writing track wasn't quite a port
of the old one because I did
start pretty much over from scratch and
that went on.
You know, I mentioned the kind of
relaxed environment at the Ingress project.
It was relaxed enough that at some
point I got involved in Trek during
a summer, and during the summer I
was paid for full-time instead of part-time,
and I spent basically all of my
full-time work working on Trek instead of
on Ingress, which they should never have
let me get away with, but it
was fun.
And there's an interesting story about Trek.
People were a lot more casual about
privacy issues back then and Ken Thompson
had root super user access to every
Unix machine on campus.
And it turns out that before he
went back to Bell labs, he made
a tape of the entire system, including
all everyone's personal files and so forth
and took it with him.
And so one day I'm working in
my office at Ingress.
At that point I was, I had
a private office because I was the
guy who did frontline support and can't
remember what my title was, but I
rated a private office and I got
this phone call.
And guy comes and says, Hi, I've
looked at your Trek program and it
looks like it's not finished yet.
Did you abandon it?
And I went, no, I did not
abandon it.
I didn't even know you had it.
Said, oh, well, Ken brought it back
from Berkeley.
So I was in the middle of
developing it.
Anyway, He and I started communicating and
sharing ideas and so forth.
That guy was named Steve Dorn, who
is known for the Bourne shell and
several other things.
So I'm still in contact with Steve.
Yeah, he always called me because it
was a long-distance call to New Jersey
and since he worked for the phone
company he got free calls and we
had very expensive calls.
So that was the arrangement.
In 1981, you had a summer job
at the International Institute for Applied Systems
Analysis in Luxembourg, Austria, Europe as a
consultant.
Can you tell us more about this
experience?
How did you get this job?
And what was your impression of Europe
in the early 80s?
So there was a guy who was
a scientist mostly working on energy related
matters.
Back before energy was a trendy thing
to work on.
And he had done stints at IASA,
International Institute for Applied Systems Analysis, aka
YASA.
And there was a guy at YASA
who was trying to build a graphic
system that the scientists could use.
And this is in the very early
days of graphic interfaces, uh certainly wasn't
you know you go down to the
corner store and buy yourself a Mac
or anything like that.
So he had collected together all of
this hardware and stuff to build it,
but they had never gotten it working.
And so somehow my friend Jerry was
able to get me an invitation to
come to do a summer at YASA
that took time off from Berkeley and
went to build this thing called feds
the front-end system, zystem I guess I
don't know and I quickly found out
why this thing had never gotten working
because every time I'd, you know, move
forward, the YASA guy would come and
say, oh, well, you know, you should
put this in, it should add this
and so forth.
So it was always like trying to
do more and I was just trying
to get it to work.
And so he and I ended up,
I guess, not really getting along all
that well, because I said no.
And I said, you know, I'm going
to get this to work.
And by God, at the end of
the summer, it worked.
It didn't work well, it didn't work
fancy, it wasn't user-friendly, It wasn't something
that the scientists could actually use, but
it did work.
And the other thing that was interesting
about that job was, it was, the
Institute itself was in a palace, one
of Maria Theresa's summer palaces.
And my office had been friends of
Joseph's library and big, huge glass doors
all around the outside of the building
so I could just walk through that
door and I'd be in a I
think it was 40 hectare park and
wander around if I wanted to stop
and think about something.
And there was a castle in the
middle of the park that was built
for Marie Antoinette as a dollhouse, but,
you know, life-sized dollhouse.
She could walk into it.
And another interesting thing about YASA was
it was, I think at that time,
the only scientific institute in the world
that had people both from the Soviet
Union and from Western governments.
So I got to know some of
the Soviets there and learned that a
lot of the stuff I'd been taught
in school maybe not have been completely
accurate.
Like these were people who, one guy
was very concerned because his wife had
to go to the hospital and she
wasn't with him, she was back in
Soviet Union.
And just the outpouring of, you know,
I can't really say love, but concern
for him, made it very clear to
me that most people in Russia just
want to live their lives kind of
like we do and that was a
good thing for me to learn.
And there was a Polish guy who
was involved with the, what was the
union, solidarity.
I actually have a solidarity union pin
around here somewhere.
And we had United Nations access, so
I had access to the UN commissary,
and everything was tax free, and all
over the world, and so forth.
It was just a splendid summer, I
have to say.
It was also my first time in
Europe, and so it's been kind of
disappointing ever since to not be in
something quite that exciting, but I love
Europe anyway.
Did you travel around Europe when you
were there?
That's right.
No, I did not.
I certainly have traveled a fair amount
since, but at that point, I remember
I was taking leave from work and
so forth.
So I kind of had to get
back.
And I was in a relationship then.
In fact, the relationship I'm still in.
And so I wanted to get back
home and be able to cuddle with
my honey.
So you were back home and in
November 1981, you joined Britton Lee, Pioneering
Relational Database Company.
So I have the feeling that some
of your colleagues at Berkeley invited you
there?
Very true.
Yes, Britton Lee was a Ingress spin-off,
kind of an interesting, maybe a little
schizophrenic company.
The people who founded it were hardware
guys and so they wanted to build
a special-purpose computer that would run database
applications.
And they didn't realize that the secret
sauce in the database system is not
the hardware, it's the software.
So there was a software group in
Berkeley, even though most of the company
was in Los Gatos.
And I got hired in initially to
manage the, what was called the host
software group, which is to say the
things that run on your computers that
talk to the database computer, we call
it a database machine.
Then it was really one of the
first cases of client-server, so it was
really a database server, but that's not
what the word was back then.
And so all of the user interfaces
that people would use, which was mostly
programmatic interfaces.
And I kind of got a group
together And one of the best hires
I've ever made, in fact, was a
guy named Greg Olson, who I'll talk
about later some more.
And, you know, we were doing some
good work, But I was having, this
was my first management job and I
did not particularly like management jobs.
So at some point I went to
my boss and I said, I wanna
go back to being an engineer, way
better at it than I am being
a manager.
And you know I'd like to do
it here and work on this stuff
but you know if you can't do
that I'll find another job.
And to his credit, he didn't say,
well, bye, see you later.
He, in fact, did put me down
to being a wine engineer again.
And by the way, did not cut
my salary amazingly.
And but the flip side is he
took this guy, Greg Olson, who was
my best engineer and made him my
boss.
And I've always wondered if he wasn't
doing that in the hopes that I
would find that such an insult that
I would quit.
Um, but in fact, Greg was the
perfect boss.
I mean, like day one, he came
in and said, Eric, you're a way
better programmer than I'll ever be.
So how about, you know, we kind
of do this together and you manage
the technology and I'll manage management.
And it worked great.
Really worked well.
I ended up doing a system there.
Um, basically I came to the conclusion
that it was too hard to build
database applications and there was no reason
the database application had to be really
difficult.
So I built a system called ADIT,
Advanced Database Interface Tools, that included a
graphic component so that you could actually
do stuff that you couldn't do on
the Fez system back in Austria.
But I got it to the point
where it was prototyped.
Still needed a lot of work.
But it was getting to the point
where it became clear that we were
going to need marketing support.
And so we did a big all
day demo.
VP of marketing came up to Berkeley,
we gave him, you know, this big
tour, showed him all the stuff it
could do.
And at the end of the day,
he said, you know, you engineers always,
you just have your heads in the
clouds.
People don't want these.
You're using Sun workstations, which are kind
of expensive at the time, I suppose.
People don't want workstations.
They're way too expensive.
They want PC applications.
They want text-only PC applications, because graphics
wasn't big on the PC.
And after I picked my job off
the floor, best I could come up
with is they will be asking for
it.
But he was like, no, no marketing
resources are going to go to this
at all.
And that's when I realized I had
to shut down the project, which I
did over, you know, sort of cleaned
it all up, documented it in the
hopes that somebody would come along and
revise it when they finally figured out
what was important.
This is part of the thing where
Britton Lee was a hardware company, not
a software company.
What I was doing was software and
hence not valuable.
And I ended up meeting up with
a friend of mine who had been
a grad student when I was at
Berkeley, and he was working at a
new place called the International Computer Science
Institute, ICSI.
And so I jumped from Britton Lee
to ICSI, which was an easy jump
to do because they were a block
apart in Berkeley.
Didn't have to rent a truck or
anything.
And am I getting too far ahead
here?
That's perfect.
Yeah, yeah, no.
So that was in 88 when you
joined the speech group at the International
Computer Science Institute, right?
Sounds about right.
I have to look at my resume.
I'm not very good on remembering dates.
Yeah, Morgan, who was known then just
as Morgan, his full name was actually
Nelson Morgan, had been working on digital
audio as a grad student in electrical
engineering.
And he got his PhD and he
went to ICSE.
He developed an interest in speech recognition
and so he started up a group
which was called the Realization Group.
There were a bunch of little groups
inside of ICSE.
It was funded by the German government,
although it was associated with Berkeley, so
we had access to Berkeley networks and
things, but we didn't get a Berkeley
paycheck.
And I had what is undoubtedly the
most spectacular office I have ever had
in my career.
It was huge.
You could probably play basketball in it.
Nice job.
But So the point of ICSI, Jerry
Feldman, who was the director of the
Institute, was a lot on these things
called neural networks.
And neural networks had been a thing
back in the 60s and then had
kind of fallen out of favor.
And he wanted to make this institute
working on what, neural networks, which were
kind of a form of artificial intelligence.
Now we call them deep learning and
it's the big rage right now.
But back then hardware was limited And
so I was in a group that
was part hardware, part software.
And the hardware folks built a thing
called the ring array processor, which was
a unusual architecture because the communication paths
could only go to the left or
to the right but couldn't go to
an arbitrary another node so a whole
bunch of computers in a box and
it turns out that was a great
architecture for doing neural networks and I
was writing software for it and I
actually didn't stay too long at ICSI
because it turns out that my job
was, let's look at, you know, eight
lines of assembly language and see if
we can get that down to seven
lines of assembly language.
And if that takes a month, so
be it.
And, you know, it was interesting.
I learned a lot about learning algorithms
and things like that.
I still have, you know, books on
my shelf from back then.
So, and I get to say, I
actually did the deep learning stuff back
before it was popular, but didn't really
spend a lot of time at it.
Nonetheless, it was fun doing something new.
It's been a theme through my career.
Some people say, okay, I'm going to
work on this, and they figure that
out in grad school and they spend
their entire career working on that and
I'm the sort of person who every
five years or so gets bored and
says I want to do something completely
different And that was completely different.
So in 1989 you moved back to
the University of California Berkeley as the
lead programmer on the Mammoth project.
Yeah.
What was the Mammoth project?
So Mammoth was an infrastructure group.
At that time, Berkeley was...
if you had a project where you
were using a computer, and at that
point pretty much everyone was on Unix.
You had your own computer and your
own system administrator, and you managed your
own machine, and everyone tended to customize
their own software.
And it was starting to become a
problem because two groups would talk to
each other and say "oh, you know
we're doing stuff that would really fit
together nicely" and then discover they couldn't
fit them together because they or use
different versions of the compiler or something.
And so, um, a professor, Susan Graham,
um, became the PI on the Mammoth
project.
And the idea was we got an
actually really big grant to install and
manage infrastructure.
And so we had a CM5 from
Thinking Machines, which was a parallel computer
at that point, which I don't quite
know how they talked thinking machines into
letting them have one for a fraction
of the price because these things...
so there's at the end of the
rack there's a panel filled with blinking
lights and you've seen it in Jurassic
Park because in the scene where the
girl goes into the machine room and
goes "Oh, this is Unix.
I know how to use this." The
machine was actually a CM5 and in
fact the guy who maintained our machine
was the one who installed that on
the set.
And it turns out there were no
processors at all in that box.
The lights flashing, there was a separate
processor just to blink the lights.
It did absolutely nothing.
And so they had an empty box.
We had a box with a few
things in it.
And that machine, that panel was so
heavy that it took two people to
lift it up.
It was just, the machine was a
disaster in terms of actually being usable
and maintainable and so forth.
Anyway, that was one of the things.
Another one was a compute machine.
This is back in the time when
people are starting to say maybe this
parallel processing stuff is a good idea.
And so they got a, oh, come
on, it was running RISC-OS.
It was a, I can't remember the
manufacturer now, but I think it was
the 32 processor system, which was about
the biggest you could get back then.
And the third one was a disk
server, which we got from another company.
And the idea was people could get
time, counts, whatever, on any of these
resources.
And that way they wouldn't have to
manage the machines themselves.
So on the disk servers we built
something called the software warehouse, which basically
said, let's find all the interesting software
that anyone might wanna use, we'll put
it in one place, it'll be shared
through the whole department, we will maintain
it.
And so all of these people who
have been spending all their time doing
system administration can actually do real research.
And it was incredibly successful.
And at a group there, at that
point, I was a manager again, but
I was getting to be better at
it And I had been in my
first management job and yeah, it was
kind of changed the whole culture in
the department.
So I was a very popular guy
in the department for a while.
But the problem with the mammoth project
is it had gotten to the point
where it was starting to become a,
okay, just keep things running.
And so it was a maintenance job.
And I was, like I said, every
five years I get itchy.
And so I got itchy and decided
to leave.
And that was 1995.
Yeah.
You joined in reference.
Yes, well, there's twice in my life
where I've taken jobs that were really
a mistake.
And I think that was one of
them.
It looked kind of cool.
But first of all, it was in
Sunnyvale, so I had to commute from
Berkeley, which was, I don't like to
drive, and so that was terrible.
But the other thing was, the guy
who founded it turns out didn't seem
to know what the product was that
he was trying to build.
And so every time I was the
chief technology officer and at that point
I had kind of a name so
he always wanted to strut me out
to show people that we had this
techie guy on his staff and I
learned to keep my mouth shut until
I found out what the product was
today.
And then I had to ad lib
it.
So that was just kind of a
disaster.
And I ended up leaving that.
It ended up getting sold off to
another place which was an internet ad
company.
So in reference turned into an internet
ad company but that was after I
left.
Trust me I wouldn't do that to
you.
So what happened when you left in
reference?
Well, that was a painful experience, both
between the commute and the uncertainty of
the job and so forth.
So I realized I had enough money
in the bank that I could probably
survive for six months without too much
trouble.
And so I was basically acting as
a consultant and I was working on
I wrote, co-authored a book on send
mail.
That was during that time I did
some other well, I did other consulting
a big one there being a company
that wanted to do mass mailing, which,
you know, now everyone has this, but
back then it was a new thing.
Anyway, I was here in Berkeley, down
at Pete's, which is two blocks from
my house getting coffee.
And who did I run into but
Greg Olson, same guy I'd worked with
at Britton Lee.
And you know, I'd had in the
back of my head a thing of,
well, maybe I could get some companies
together and create a consortium that, you
know, they'd each give me a small
amount of money to develop and maintain
Sendmail.
I could hire somebody to do the
frontline support, which was taking up more
and more of my time.
You know, free email consulting.
I was spending half my day every
day just answering mail, most of which
was, see this page.
It's documented, look it up.
So I had gone to some couple
other places and the general attitude seemed
to be, yeah, we would fund you
for that as long as we own
it.
And I'm
like, no, that's not the point.
Point is, if ownership is spread out
and nobody would go for that and
so Greg at that point had gone
stayed on the management route and he
had been you know VP of marketing,
and VP of engineering and VP of
sales and so forth.
So you had all of these, this
background and how companies actually work.
And I told him about this and
he said, you know, I'm between jobs
right now and I'm kind of doing
business consulting and I'll help you write
a business plan.
You could do a company, you know,
just a standalone company.
And so we spent that summer working
on a business plan.
And when the whole thing came together,
I basically said, I'll give you half
the company if you'd be my CEO.
And so he did that and was
a really great CEO.
And yeah, it was pretty heady.
We made the front page of the
New York Times when we announced the
company.
So that was in March 1998.
Yes, that's right.
It was.
I was thinking it was earlier, but
no, that's right.
So you know, we, SendMail had a
reputation for being difficult to configure so
our first thing was we'll make it
easy to configure and using a graphic
user interface and so forth.
And, well, I could go through the
whole history of SendMail, but probably it's
only of interest to three people in
the world.
So, if there's anything in particular you're
interested in.
The evolution of the company, when you
founded it, and what happened eventually.
And what were the key events?
So I was Chief Technology Officer.
I was acting as VP of engineering
at first but we had to get
another VP of engineering because two things
actually one was part of VP of
engineering is doing budgets and things like
that which was not something that really
got me excited.
But the other thing was, and this
is probably a mistake I made at
Sendmail, the marketing department at that point,
I really had a reputation.
So the marketing department wanted to, you
know, bring me out to speak in
front of customers and stuff, you know,
at conferences, etc.
So, I ended up flying all over
the world, meeting customers.
There was one time when I had
been in Europe for, you know, probably
four or five different countries in Europe,
had to fly back to Berkeley for
some meeting or event, and the very
next day flew to Japan.
So it was kind of grueling.
And so I ended up doing more
marketing actually than technology, which kind of
bummed me out.
We did get some important things done
here.
We came up with the Miltur interface,
stood for mail filter.
And that was a way to do
plugins into SendMail to do mail filtering,
which can be arbitrary, but of course
the big thing back then was anti-spam.
Spam was becoming a really serious problem.
The milter interface was very successful to
the extent that other MTAs that are
out there are compatible with the SendMail
milters.
And I worked on some standards for
the IETF, the Internet Engineering Task Force,
which sets the standards for the Internet.
In particular one called DKIM, Domain Keys
Identified Mail.
I...
The standards process is an interesting one.
And I ended up, I did that
and then decided I didn't wanna do
standards anymore just because it was tedious.
And there were some people there who
were very, very difficult to work with,
and you couldn't get rid of them.
So that was the end of my
standards career.
And then, this is gonna sound a
little bizarre, but one of my lucky
breaks was I was diagnosed with prostate
cancer.
And I know you don't think of
that as a lucky break, but I
was 51, 52, I think then.
And so I decided I would have
surgery.
And there was, of course, a recovery
period from surgery.
And so I ended up taking some
time off and eventually went to part
time.
And that got me a little bit
away and you know, I continued working
there for a while but realized that
I'd come in once a week and
say hi to people but that was
not all I was doing and I
don't like doing jobs which are nothing,
you know, getting paid to do nothing.
Didn't sit well with me.
So at that some point I left
Sendmail, which was right about the time
it was acquired by Proofpoint.
And things worked out pretty well actually.
The customers, all the products continued to
be supported.
The employees, except for upper management, kept
their jobs.
And, you know, it was, you know,
I'm kind of sorry that Sendmail didn't
turn into a big star, but it
wasn't adequate result.
Unfortunately, the investors, myself included, didn't do
very well.
So what did you do when you
left SendMail?
Yeah, that was the second time I
made a kind of job mistake.
I went to work at a company
in San Francisco, which perhaps I shouldn't
name, but doing streaming database queries.
So taking SQL and instead of having
it say, here's the data, you know,
tell me what the average salary is,
it would watch the data as it
came through, computing things and picking out
other things, which was actually an interesting
idea.
It's actually a pretty good idea.
But it was, the coding was all
in C++, a language that I despise,
and Java, a language which I didn't
really know.
And the management at that company was
very, very proud of the fact that
they had a million lines of source
code.
And they're like, ooh, we're gonna tell
everyone how much source code we have.
And the engineers are all going, no,
don't do it.
We have a million lines of source
code because we couldn't figure out how
to make it smaller.
And so that was a very demoralizing.
I think I did one, you know,
made one innovation where I discovered an
N squared algorithm in the thing, but
which was, you know, that's a big
deal.
But I felt like I wasn't succeeding
very well.
And I was thinking, you know, maybe
after all that time at Sendmail where
I basically wasn't writing any code anymore
and maybe I just couldn't do it
anymore.
So I ended up putting my tail
between my legs and gave that one
up.
In 2011 you kind of retired.
So what did you do?
Well, yeah, I I did actually try
to retire I..
you know did some but I was
basically saying okay, you know at this
point I've got enough money in the
bank.
You know, Sendmail was paying me pretty
well, but I live a pretty frugal
lifestyle.
So I had actually amassed a nice
nest egg.
And so back in my mammoth days,
one of the things that happened was
the computer science department moved into a
new building and so all of those
computers and things that I was talking
about had to move from the old
building into the new building and the
new building had to have a whole
new network and so forth.
And I worked with another staff member,
a guy named Ken Lutz, who as
near as I can tell has worked
on every interesting project that Berkeley has
ever done in computer science.
He's, you know, did RAID and network
abort stations and all these really cool
projects.
So I ran into him, actually, no,
I didn't run into him.
He called me, I guess, and said,
you know, Eric, I'm working at a
new research lab called the Swarm Lab
at Berkeley.
And there's some stuff going on here
I think you might find interesting.
And we have seminars at lunchtime on
Thursdays, free lunch.
Why don't you come up and see
what we're doing?" I went, well sure,
okay, free lunch, got me.
And so I went up and indeed
it was very interesting.
Now this was the first time I've
been in a lab which looked like
a lab.
This is where they have oscilloscopes and
signal generators and microscopes and heavy duty
chemicals and so forth.
And I was a software guy.
But it was still really interesting stuff.
And so I ended up hanging out
at a research project and at some
point was hanging out enough that they
ended up hiring me.
So I went back to work, working
for the university.
And so that I believe will be
the last job of my career unless
something changes.
So I bracketed my career with university
jobs, which, you know, I'm not unhappy
about that.
And I do have to say like
I said after I finished with the
previous company I was really kind of
demoralized, convinced that I just couldn't program
anymore.
And I ended up writing most of
the code for that research project and
kind of got my mojo back.
So it was a good job and
I loved working with him.
He was absolutely fabulous guy.
So during your career, you received many
honors and in particular, In 2014, you
were inducted to the Internet Hall of
Fame.
Yes.
Did you expect that?
Did I expect that?
Not at all.
Yeah, I don't quite remember how it
even came about but yeah, I flew
to Hong Kong for that ceremony and
you know, they they made a big
deal out of it.
And they end up having a whole
bunch of really interesting people.
It turns out I already personally knew
some of the inductees, including Paul Bixey,
who was inducted the same time I
was.
So he and I ran around Hong
Kong together.
That was pretty cool.
And yeah, you know, it was obviously
for internet mail.
And they had some clever way of
making it sound more important than it
actually was.
But there you go.
You have been involved in Usenix since
the 70s, 1970s.
Yes.
What have been your roles in the
years?
So, so I started just attending USENIX.
The first USENIX I went to was
in San Francisco.
And Tom Ferron, who I mentioned earlier,
was chairing that conference.
And it was an amazingly wonderful conference.
It's like you know I'm with my
people here This is great and so
I started going to more conferences and
eventually I ended up on the board
of directors and did that for several
years and several different roles I think
I was Vice President at one point
and Treasurer another point.
But there are term limits on the
using sport, which is a good thing.
I believe in term limits and so
I'm still however on the audit committee.
So every year we get together and
go through the audits of the finances
to make sure there's no hanky-panky going
on.
So I'm still connected with these things.
So you publish several papers, books, articles.
What is the publication you are most
proud of?
You know, I don't know that I
would say pride exactly.
You know some of them have been
important.
There's been you know papers that came
out with important.
There's been papers that came out associated
with Ingress that have made an impact.
I was on the editorial review board
of, not unit review, that's a different
one, of ACM Q Magazine.
And as a result of being on
that board, wrote a lot of articles
for Q, which was designed more for
practitioners.
So it wasn't, you know, hardcore bits
and bytes.
And one of those, managing technical debt,
turns out to now be probably my
most referenced paper ever.
People are referencing it all over the
place.
You know, I think it's a good
paper, you know, article, really, not a
paper.
But I don't quite understand why that's
more important than some of the other
ones I've done.
You know, obviously, the Sendmail book was
a big deal at the time.
It was a...
O'Reilly and Associates said it was their
best-selling book for several years.
So Brian Costales was the primary author
on that, so I can't really take
the credit for that one.
I don't know.
I mean, I try and do, I
try and feel at least not embarrassed
by anything I publish.
So I don't know if that means
proud.
I guess it's more important what has
actually had impact and Those two things
are probably the ones that have had
the most impact.
So what activities have you pursued recently?
Yeah, well I retired from the university
in and you know really retired from
the university this time as in, you
know, I'm getting a pension.
And so, you know, I still do
technology work and so forth.
I'm a wine collector.
And so I built a database to
store the inventory of our wine cellar.
And that's all in Python, which was
a language I had to learn in
order to do this.
And I'm kind of the default system
administrator for the house, which I kind
of hate, but somebody has to do
it.
I got involved in a place called
the Hillside, Berkeley Hillside Club, several years
ago, originally just as a member.
Hillside Club is a member organization focusing
on basically art, architecture, you know, certain
current event things, climate change, et cetera.
And at some point ended up, I
didn't get out of the way fast
enough and I ended up being elected
to the board.
And I just literally a few days
ago, turned out and I ultimately ended
up as President.
And I'm this President for two years
and I'm gratified that many people have
told me that I was actually a
good President.
So I almost feel like now that
I've retired, I may have gotten this
management thing working.
And actually after swearing I would never
start another company again in my life.
I started another company called the, it's
a not-for-profit called the Berkeley Historic Building
Fund.
And it's to collect money to maintain
historic buildings, including the building that the
Hillside Club is in.
So we are interested in getting a
new roof and things like that.
So I'm kind of doing, you know,
more social things now, not so much
serious tech.
Okay, let's go back to many years
ago.
So In 1976, you came out of
the closet.
You already mentioned your partner.
But what I wanted to ask you
is, what happened in 1976?
How you did it and what was
its impact in those days, in the
mid-70s?
I was in an emotionally very, very
bad way.
I won't go into the gory details,
but it became very clear to me
that I had to come out and
I didn't even want to consider the
alternative.
And that was probably the best decision
I've ever made in my life.
You know, I lost some friends.
You know, when I came out of
the closet, I didn't just like open
the door, I used dynamite to blow
it open.
And I was working on the Ingress
Project back then.
And there were some people who were
clearly concerned about that.
But a whole bunch of the other
people were like, yay for you.
And some of those people remained some
of my best friends.
But more importantly, I think I mentioned
kind of an angry personality for a
while.
You know, some of that was, you
know, frankly, I got some of it
from my father, but a lot of
it was just pent up, you know,
self-hatred, I guess.
And that let me open up.
And, You know, like I said, there
were people who, you know, I lost,
but it gave me a path to
being an easier to get along with
person.
And so I think it, you know,
completely changed my personality.
I'm much less of an asshole than
I was before.
And, you know, I did at some
point meet a guy who was actually
a student at Berkeley.
I was still on the Ingress project,
but I was out at that point
and at the time he was in
the closet and so it didn't go
well and for a couple of years
if we saw each other in the
hallway, we'd both turn around and walk
the other direction.
But then went to a gay students
union meeting once, which I almost never
did, but I did that day and
who would be in the room but
the same guy, tried to hide behind
a pillow.
And we've been together ever since, 44
years.
So in 1998, you said in an
interview, there is some sort of perverse
pleasure in knowing that it's basically impossible
to send a piece of hate mail
out through the internet without...(voice gets cut)
Yeah, that was a period where there
was a lot of sort of Christian
fundamentalism that somehow was sneaking into the
technology world.
Somebody was proposing a new version of
Unix called Yazix, I think.
And you know, there would be no
kill command because you know to kill
as a sin so they renamed that
and they obviously they had to get
rid of some mail because it was
written by what do they say a
well-known gay activist or something like that.
I don't remember exactly what it was.
And I can't even remember when or
where I said that or to whom,
But it was just kind of an
offhanded, you know, aside.
And Sendmail survived and Yazix or whatever
they were calling it didn't.
So I win.
Would you like to say anything else
about your husband?
Sure, Kirk McKusick, another kind of luminary.
I know you've interviewed him.
He shared an office with Bill Joy,
so I knew Bill pretty well.
He's one of those people he Actually
what he it's PhD was in table
driven register allocation for compilers, something like
that.
Something that he has used, I think,
once in his career.
Although it turns out that his PhD
thesis is now referenced by a bunch
of people because as computers get to
the point where they have more and
more registers, the algorithms that he came
up with are completely the right things,
but that's not what he's working on
He started working on the file system
for Unix.
Once again, Bill Joy saying "hey Kirk,
you know, why don't you work on
this?" and Bill was really good at
getting other people to do things.
And he wrote what was called at
the time the FAST file system.
It's now been renamed UFS, the Unix
file system, because it's essentially the default
Unix file system for everyone.
But he's kept on it.
And he has added all kinds of
stuff, Background FSCK, for example, so you
didn't have to wait forever for the
system to reboot.
And snapshots, so you could get a
backup of a clean file system that
wasn't changing out from under you and
and and and and and.
He's done recently a bunch of work
for Netflix, kind of counterintuitive.
Netflix uses this file system to distribute
the actual movies that are on the
internet.
And the discs that they use, every
day they rewrite them in the middle
of the night predicting what is going
to be valuable the next day and
so if a disc dies we have
as many discs as Netflix does there's
always a dead disc They didn't want
the whole system to crash.
They just wanted the system to say,
oh, that disk went away, okay, I'll
just skip over that.
And so they actually paid him to
do that work on the condition that
it go into the open source.
So the whole world benefits from that.
So yeah, he's still working on file
systems.
Have you ever worked together or collaborated
on a project?
Yeah, many of them.
Well, I kind of worked on Trek
with Steve, Steve Warren.
The ADIT project had multiple programmers on
it.
There was one guy in particular, uh,
who, uh, kind of, we did kind
of co-coding for big chunks of it.
So we'd actually go into the office
at night when we wouldn't get interrupted
and spend all night, you know, two
computers in the office and working on
the code, handing stuff back and forth.
Yeah, there's been lots of people who
I've done some kind of work with.
That experience with the, with, um, at
Britain Lee was probably the tightest I've
ever worked with anyone before.
Others have been, you know, the surgical
team model where there's, you know, one
guy in charge and other people who
are scattered around the side.
Husband?
With Kirk?
One thing about a successful relationship is
it may be important to not work
too intimately on projects.
There's a lot of stuff we've done
together, you know, carpentry around the house
and so forth.
But it's like cooking together.
We learned a long time ago that
we can cook together as long as
we know who's making dinner and who's
helping.
And it trades off which is which.
Doesn't really matter, it's not like one
of us has to be in control
all the time, but if we try
and negotiate everything, it can be a
problem.
Bigly I agree with you.
So, what is your main motivation in
supporting free and open source software?
You know, if I'm going to be
gallant, I'll make some comment about making
the world a better place, etc., etc.
If I'm going to be a little
more honest, I think it's just because
I really love it when people use
the stuff I've written.
And the easiest way to do that
is to give it away.
So I have, my whole career, I
have not gone for the jobs that
make the most money.
I've gone to the jobs that most
interest me, you know, and assumed that
the money would sort of follow along.
And, you know, I could be way,
way richer than I am right now.
But why?
I've got enough money that I can
retire comfortably, and I can't buy islands
or fly private jets or anything like
that.
But I'm happy.
And so, yeah, just having people use
the work.
You know, I love it when somebody
comes up and says, oh, I use,
you know, whatever, Sendmail, whatever, and you
know, I loved it.
That just makes me all warm inside.
So if you look at your life,
what is the thing you're the most
proud of?
Most proud of in my life, it's,
I'm tempted to say coming out of
the closet because it made my life
a lot better and frankly the lives
of other people around me a lot
better.
SendMail obviously had an incredible impact.
SendMail is still out there on the
internet but it's nowhere near the market
share that it used to have.
That's okay.
Syslog turned out to be really, really
important.
And once again, it's been rewritten.
It's not my code anymore, but it
was my idea.
You know, the environment at the computer
science department at Berkeley, where I had
something to do with building it, I'm
really proud of.
It really improved the ability for researchers
to get their jobs done across the
entire department.
It wasn't just my group, it was
the whole department.
And that's really pretty cool.
You know, the honors and stuff don't
mean that much to me.
You know, I mean, it's nice to
be recognized, but it's not like I,
you know, have plaques all around my
office, you know, showing off the awards
that I've gotten.
I think that's tacky.
What advice would you give to someone
willing to pursue a career today?
Well, it depends on what your goals
in life are, I guess.
Like it's said, I've done the bit
of going on and doing whole bunches
of different things, which means I've learned
a lot, means I'm probably never the
best at anything at any given time
because I'm the one who's learning about
it.
But there's a famous guy, won the
Turing Award, Jim Gray, who sadly was
lost at sea several years ago.
And Jim was a friend of mine.
And his thing was doing massive databases.
And he would pick something that had
never been done before and then do
it.
And these things were earth changing, in
some senses quite literally.
Maps, the database technology that we have
to store maps that you use from
everyone today was developed by Jim.
And the thing about Jim was he,
when he went into a new thing,
he didn't just say, okay, what's the,
what do I as a computer scientist
need to know?
He said he wants to understand the
technology or the science that is applied.
So his last project was working on
the sky map, said, you know, well,
what's bigger than the whole planet?
Oh, how about the whole universe?
And when he was honored after he
passed away, somebody on that project said,
Jim came in and he said, I
want to learn about astronomy, not what's
your data problem.
He said, I want to understand astronomy.
And he started actually making serious contributions
to the project.
I think that's great.
And if you can do it, that's
wonderful.
But I remember chatting with him at
some point, and he was working at
Microsoft, and he said, they're paying me
an obscene amount of money for work
that I would happily do for free
if they just gave me the resources
to do it with.
This was a perfect life and so
if you can get the perfect life,
go for it.
You know other people like Kirk are
very happy to you know kind of
carve out this area and you know
if you carve out an area don't
make it too small don't make it
too big.
So, yeah, I would definitely say you
know followed the interest don't follow the
money obviously, we need enough to be
able to put food in the refrigerator
and so forth.
But I think a lot of people
going into deep learning AI today are
doing it because they think there's, data
scientists are going to make a huge
amount of money.
And that's true, some of them will,
but there's so many people going into
it right now that there will be
a glut of data scientists in a
few years.
And I did neural networks when neural
networks were out of favor.
And I kind of like doing stuff
that is not popular and having it
become popular later.
The database interfaces, graphical database interfaces that
I mentioned earlier, you know, three years
later that's what everyone wanted.
And that VP of marketing was an
idiot.
So, do something exciting, do something that's
challenging, and enjoy it.
Is there anything you would like to
add that you haven't covered today?
Probably tons of things.
But I was thinking of something earlier,
but I've lost it.
So I'm just going to say no.
Okay.
We can cover this in another interview,
perhaps?
Maybe.
Okay, so thank you.
It's been a real pleasure talking to
you today.
Yes, it's been a pleasure talking with
you too.
It's kind of fun to reminisce.
Thank you very much.